Venture for America is a nonprofit fellowship
program for college graduates who want to
learn how to build businesses and create opportunities,
become entrepreneurs really.
What we do is we recruit top grads.
We bring them to a training camp for five
weeks at Brown University, my alma mater.
We bring in entrepreneurs, investors, venture
capitalists, McKenzie, IDO to help train them
in what it takes to build a company.
And then they work in startup companies in
Detroit, New Orleans, Providence, Cincinnati
and eight other U.S. cities for two years.
And at the end of those two years they’ll
have a sense of how these businesses grow
and develop.
They’ll be working with a more experienced
entrepreneur during that time.
At the end of the two years they can either
stay at that company as a manager and leader
or they can even start their own companies.
And we have a set of angel investors and a
seed fund to invest in them.
So you can think of it as a two year extended
entrepreneur apprenticeship program that has
the immediate effect of helping companies
expand and hire more people and hopefully
create more jobs.
Our immediate goal as an organization is to
help create 100,000 new U.S. jobs by 2025
by helping these companies grow and also training
the next generation of entrepreneurs.
So there are six default paths for young smart
people in the U.S. today – financial services,
management/consulting, law school, medical
school, graduate school/academia and Teach
for America.
So these are six things and these six things
will comprise between 50 and 70 percent of
university graduates from any national university
in the U.S. I mean they really add up very
quickly.
They also tend to concentrate our talent in
one of six geographies – New York City,
San Francisco/Silicon Valley, Washington D.C.,
Boston, Chicago and L.A.
So in essence we have a system that’s driving
our most talented graduates to one of six
activities in one of six places.
And over the long term this is not a great
thing for the economy, especially if you consider
that so many of these graduates are heading
to professional services contexts that exist
to serve essentially large companies that
after they get big enough to a point where
they can hire an investment banker, consulting
firm or a law firm.
So the metaphor I use is that it’s like
we’re investing in tons of layers of icing
and forgetting to bake the cake.
What we need to do is we need to send more
talent to early stage businesses that can
grow and prosper, expand, hire people, maybe
even create hundreds of new jobs.
And then if they become mature then they can
hire professional services firms to help them
expand in various ways.
But the first order of business is helping
the firms come into being and to grow.
36 percent of this year’s Venture for America
class was comprised of women.
And we think that’s a good start but not
nearly where it needs to be.
We need to get it up to 51 percent to mirror
the population and also the college graduate
ratio obviously.
You know, I think people respond very powerfully
to role models.
Like they see examples, they want to see someone
who’s like them.
And so there are some fellows that are women
that come to us and say hey, I’d prefer
a female led company.
And so when we go out to the startup landscape
in these cities and you look around, I mean
the proportion of companies that right now
– not even in tech but just, you know, in
startups and growth companies in these cities
– unfortunately it’s certainly well below
51 percent at least of the companies that
we see and interact with.
And so, you know, we see there’s a lot of
work to do at every level.
But we think a lot of it does begin as women
looking up and saying like hey, who are the
people that are doing this that are like me.
And I think that’s one reason why someone
like Sheryl Sandberg has set such a huge powerful
example because now, you know, women look
up and see that there are leaders in these
industries that are women that are doing amazing
things.
I think there’s certainly a desire among
this generation to have a positive impact
to build something new.
And I see this when I interact with college
students around the country that they very
badly want that sort of option.
But when the rubber hits the road it’s really
about who’s making them a job offer when.
And so if you’re a senior in college and
you’re looking for a job, it’s all about
who’s extending you a genuine path and who’s
recruiting you, who’s making you feel wanted,
who can you take home to your parents figuratively
speaking and say hey, mom, guess what?
I’ve got an offer from Deloitte.
Then your parents will be very, very happy.
So those are the variables that really matter.
Like people talk about the, you know, the
wants and needs of the generation which are
obviously very important.
But it’s equally important what are the
genuine choices they’re being presented
with.
And those things are a function of resources.
So what Venture for America does is we try
and provide a genuine path toward startups
and growth companies in Detroit and New Orleans
and other parts of the country that might
not be top of mind for a recent college graduate
really by extending some of the same resources.
So that if you join VFA you’ll end up with
some of the same network and community and
training and support that many of these young
people are seeking through other means.